Jimmy thing here I'm gonna show you how
to change out your ps4 slims slow 5400
rpm hard drive with a larger faster SSD
let's begin the only thing you'll need
is a Philips head screwdriver
so then what you're gonna do is turn the
playstation 4 back around pay station
for slim has a interesting little
pop-out thing here but you can just open
up with your hands you'll then see a one
screw that requires like a Philips head
screwdriver
go ahead and grab your Philips head
screwdriver and open that up this allows
you to pull the hard drive out with this
little strip which makes it easier to
pull out from here the laptop drive
inside has four screws that hold it in
place we're just going to go ahead and
unscrew it once you have all four screws
out go ahead and take the laptop drive
out we're gonna be replacing the hard
drive with a 960 gigabyte HyperX savage
SSD which is basically a one terabyte
drive you can actually replace it with
any 2.5 inch SSD or laptop drive over go
ahead and slap the SSD in place make
sure that the four screw holes are
aligned and then screw them back in once
you have the SSD mounted to the cage
you're going to go ahead and slide it
back inside
from there you're gonna take that one
loose screw and screw it back in once
you have it screwed in you're gonna go
ahead and put the covering back on top
the next thing you'll want to do is
download the dot pu p firm or a file on
playstation comm from there get a flash
drive with at least nine hundred
megabytes of free space and make sure
it's formatted to fat32 if it's not
formatted to fat32 you can reformat it
in associate using a PC create a folder
that says ps4 in the USB Drive and then
inside that folder create one that says
update make sure that there are all end
caps and this is where you want to put a
dot pu p flat once the stick is ready to
go insert it into the ps4 slim also make
sure to have the ps4 slim controller
plugged into the console itself since we
removed the hard drive it won't have the
firmware to work wirelessly with the
console turned off go ahead and press
the power button and hold it for roughly
seven seconds now we're going to go
ahead and press the PlayStation 4 button
and then we're going to choose
initialize ps4 reinstall system software
the USB drive is already connected so we
need to sit okay
after installing the SSD we ran some
simple boot tests turning on the system
took 14 seconds which is nine seconds
faster than the original hard drive
waking up from sleep took four seconds
which is 10 seconds faster than the
original head day finally launching the
game Paragon took 46 seconds which
shaved off 16 seconds and there you have
it that's how you replace a slow smaller
hard drive with a faster larger SSD